if you keep thinking the same thoughts
if you keep making the same choices you
keep doing the same things you keep
creating the same experiences you keep
feeling the same emotions I don't know
let's be conservative he did that for 10
years you would have to agree with you
then that it would become more automatic
if you become more unconscious your
personality creates your personal
reality that's it that is it and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so keep
thinking the same way keep acting the
same way keep feeling the same way your
personality is the same and your
personal reality will be the same as
well so if you wanted to change your
life if you wanted to change your
personal reality you would have to
change your personality and then you'd
have to start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and decide if you
really want to believe that any longer
and when does the story end it's that
moment that you become so conscious of
that thought you're so tired of it
you're so aware of it that you would
never let it slip by your awareness ever
again hey seven Carmichael and I make
these videos because running the
business is hard and waking up every day
and get in the work when you're all by
yourself is hard and the thing that
saved me that continues to inspire me
motivate me give me hope inspiration
ideas is looking at the stories of
people who've done a lot more than me
and I learned strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's learn
how to unlock the unlimited power of our
mind with Dr Joe dispenza enjoy
you catch yourself complaining and
blaming and making excuses and feeling
sorry for yourself and that's been your
unconscious program
then the moment you become conscious of
those unconscious behaviors
you're out of the program you're only in
the program when you're unconscious and
so it takes an enormous amount of energy
and awareness to separate from those
programs
and then there's those emotions that we
feel every single day that are so
familiar to us that we don't even know
what they are
we just feel guilty we don't even know
what's guilt it's just how we feel
and the stronger the emotions that we
have to
experiences in our life the more altered
we are inside of us the chemistry
changes inside of us the brain Narrows
the focus on the cause and takes a
snapshot
or a series of snapshots and that's
called a long-term memory
and so then makes total sense then that
a person by every time they relive that
event in their life they're making the
same chemistry and their brain and their
body and their bodies literally
believing it's living that experience
over and over again
and now the body's so in the past
that it's the mind of the past
so then
the act of becoming so conscious that
you don't go unconscious
is a changing of consciousness
how many times do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that is the moment of change
rule number two is Master your thoughts
the majority of the thoughts that we
think every single day are the same
thoughts as we thought yesterday
and in fact ninety percent of them are
and the same thoughts leading to the
same choices the same choices leading to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
creating the same experiences and the
same experiences producing the same
feelings and emotions
begins to cause our biology
to become very similar very same and
the repetition of that and firing and
wiring then creates automatic programs
in the brain and body and 95 percent of
who we are is a state of unconscious or
subconscious programs where we've done
something so many times that the body
now can actually do it automatically
without the conscious mind if you truly
wanted a change and you understood that
your personality creates your personal
reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think how you act and how you feel
and the present personality who's
listening to this call has created the
present personal reality called their
life that means if they wanted to create
a new personal reality a new life they
would have to begin to change their
personality they'd have to change
themselves and most people then try to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality it doesn't work
so then if you're sitting in your
meditation and you ask yourself the
question who do I want to be when I open
my eyes what is the greatest expression
of myself
and you said okay let me remind myself
of how I no longer want to think
you know the thoughts like
whatever it's too hard I'll never change
I'll never get what I want let me become
so conscious
of those unconscious thoughts that I
wouldn't let that thought slit by my
awareness today unnoticed by me and
program my autonomic nervous system in
the specific outcome
and then if you said how would I want to
speak today
how do I want to act how do I want to
behave and you reminded yourself how you
weren't going to act and how you weren't
going to behave and you became conscious
of those unconscious habits to such a
degree you wouldn't go unconscious and
behave in the same way that's when
you're no longer the program now your
Consciousness observing the program if
you said when is my energy drop when
when what do I feel when I feel those
typical familiar emotions what are they
uh so let me name them just so I'm so
aware of them that my energy drops I can
catch myself in that moment and not
return back to the same familiar
emotions
and cause my body to believe it's back
in the past and we can't see a new
future from the past so that process
then
is what I call getting beyond the old
self and it's a disentangling from the
program the word meditation means to
become familiar with so as you sit there
and become familiar with those states of
Mind and Body you begin to objectify
your subjective self now now you are you
are becoming so aware of the unconscious
programs you won't go unconscious and
that's the first step to change and then
what if you said what thoughts do I want
to fire and wire in my brain what
thoughts do I want to put my attention
behind and begin to install the new
circuitry the new hardware and if I keep
my attention on it and I fire and wire
those thoughts it's going to begin to
become a software program and that's
going to be the new voice in my head
that's going to be the voice that's
telling me the new program that you can
that it is possible rule number three is
practice repetition every time you learn
something new you make new Connections
in your brain that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections
and as you begin to leave imprints in
your neurological tissue as a result of
your interaction in the environment
the next thing is that you're going to
have an opportunity then to apply that
information
the personalizing to demonstrate it
and a certain people group of people
will get their behaviors to match their
intentions
to get their actions equal to their
thoughts they'll step out into the
unknown
and let's try it and when they do
they'll have a new experience
and experience then enriches the brain
reorganizing more circuits than what you
understood physiologically
but the moment those neurons string into
place
the brain makes a chemical and that
chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and the moment you feel Unlimited
the moment you feel like a patient
parent the moment you feel abundant the
moment you feel free
now you are teaching your body
chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood
so we can say knowledge is for the mind
and experiences for the body
and in that moment you're beginning to
embody the truth of that philosophy of
that theory and you're literally
signaling new genes in new ways and you
are rewriting your biological program
but if you've done it once
it must mean you can do it again
and if you can repeat any experience
over and over again you are going to
neurochemically condition your mind and
body to begin to work as one
and we've done something so many times
that the body now knows how to do it as
well as the mind now it's becoming
innate in you
it's second nature it's easy it's
familiar
it's who you are
as a matter of fact you've practiced it
so many times that you don't even have
to consciously think about it because
it's becoming a subconscious program
so our job
is to go from philosopher
to initiate to master
from knowledge to experience to wisdom
from mind to body to Soul
from thinking to doing to being to
learning it with your head practicing it
with your hands and knowing it by heart
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is Embrace change
I wanted to listen to the questions that
people asked and the questions were okay
you create your reality I get it how do
you do it
I thought it was a brilliant question
next question is okay your personality
creates your personal reality your
personality is made by how you think how
you act and how you feel if I want to
change my personal reality I got to
change my personality nothing changes in
my life till I change how do we change
why is it so hard to change and then the
last question was what do you do and so
we started teaching these events you
know around the world and and giving
people some tools and basic neuroscience
and epigenetics and brain waves and
electromagnetism building a model and
you know at the end of an event people
would say I I feel a little better you
know I have a better sense of well-being
but we weren't seeing any dramatic
changes in people's health and then it
took about a year
and we just I was running these events
and every time I'd run an event someone
say can you do another one
somebody did a more evolved version and
then we did another evolve version and
then I said I don't know anything else
I don't know anything else and then I
started having profound mystical
experiences and that changed my view of
the world dramatically and I remember at
one event
this woman with Ms sitting in a
wheelchair after one meditation stood up
out of that throne and started dancing
around
and when I saw that happening I knew
something
had to be taking place inwardly in her
in other words
there must have been some Gene
regulation
that happened as a result of her inner
process and that's when everything
changed for me that's when I got a team
of scientists and neuroscientists and
biologists and partnered with heart math
Institute we started building this model
of understanding of 18 000 brain scans
now
the thousands and thousands of HR V
measurements we got Gene testing that's
done telomere testing that's not immune
regulation you know thousands of
different metabolites at this point I I
wanted to see if that person's
subjective experience of whatever that
was could be calibrated objectively and
once we understood that information can
we teach transformation better
and if you can do it and capture that
information and teach transformation
better you can shorten the distance
between really the thought and the
experience of what a person wants and
and I think that the science has become
the Contemporary language to demystify
that process and once you use tradition
or culture religion
divide an audience but science creates
community and people want to use that as
a language now it's the Contemporary
language you communicate with your
patients in terms of science I mean how
many people here run a clinic and the
first thing you say to a patient when
they start talking about their health
condition is that's not true I used to
say that every day that's not true that
is not the truth
so then that information then that
people are beginning to understand is is
theoretical and philosophical and now
there's too many testimonials I mean
we're just talking backstage every
single day we have something that
challenges my belief
a challenge is my belief and what's
possible and when I see the scientists
running the same
study over and over again
he's running the same study five times
over again then changing the study and
running it a different way and getting
the same result I know he's changing his
belief right there I know she's changing
her belief they're looking for something
else to occur and actually doesn't this
is new information it's a discovery rule
number five is change your old habits
how many people in this audience
actually believe in the idea that the
way you think has some effect on your
life that's your thoughts create your
life you believe that yes
so how many people here actually woke up
this morning
and consciously created a future
you know the biggest reason why people
don't do it
is because you don't really believe it's
true
you see if you knew on a gut level that
it was absolutely true
would you ever miss a day come on
and would you ever let any thoughts slip
by your awareness that you didn't want
to experience
so your brain according to Neuroscience
is organized to reflect everything you
know in your life
your brain is a record of your
environment
it's a record an artifact of your past
so if you believe this then then does
your environment control your thinking
or does your thinking control your
environment
so if you wake up in the morning
and you get out of bed on the same exact
side as you did the day before you shut
the alarm clock off with the same finger
you slip into your favorite slippers you
Shuffle into the bathroom and you use
the toilet like you always do
then you walk over to the mirror and you
look at yourself to remember who you are
then you get into the shower and you
wash yourself in the same routine way
then you groom yourself to look like
everybody expects you to look
then you go downstairs and you drink
coffee out of your favorite mug then you
drive the work the same way as you did
the day before
you see the same people that push the
same emotional buttons
you do the exact thing that you know how
to do and you memorize and can do so
well that you're an expert at then you
hurry up and rush home so you can hurry
up and check your emails so you could
hurry up and go to bed so you can hurry
up and do it all over again
now here's my question did your brain
change at all that day
we could say that you were thinking the
same thoughts performing the same
actions that create the same experiences
that produce the same emotions but
secretly expecting something to change
in your life would you agree
so then
as the environment turns on different
circuits in your brain you begin to
think equal to your environment as you
see the same people and go to the same
places and do the same things at the
same time it's the external environment
that's turning on different circuits in
your brain causing you to think equal to
everything that you know
and as long as you think equal to
everything that's familiar or known to
you what do you keep creating more of
same life now the quantum law is still
applying to you you're just thinking
equal to everything that you know and
you keep creating more of the same
to change
to truly change is to think greater than
your environment and every great person
in history knew this whether it was
William Wallace or Mahatma Gandhi or
Martin Luther King or Queen Elizabeth
the first or Joan of Arc they all had a
vision
they all had an idea couldn't see it
couldn't smell it couldn't taste it
couldn't feel it but it was alive in
their mind
it was so alive in their mind that they
began to live as if that reality was
actually happening now
so can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already happened
Neuroscience says it's absolutely
possible and rule number six the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is practice meditation we teach
meditation three ways to become familiar
with your old self and to become
familiar with your new self that's what
the word meditation means
familiarization to become familiar with
so we use that model for change so slow
your brain waves down and get beyond
your analytical mind this meditation and
you teach your body how to do that and
we've discovered a formula that that
simply makes it very easy for people to
do it you practice it you'll get good at
it just like anything else you practice
so so to get beyond the analytical mind
there's another way to reprogram
ourselves and then meditation is really
about getting beyond your body
or disconnecting from your body
disconnecting from your environment and
forgetting about time and that is that
eye of the needle where we begin to make
the most significant changes so we're
data driven you know we're really
looking to see what it is and and when
we see brains respond in the same way it
helps me
enormously to teach the material better
and so the more people understand what
they're doing
and the more they understand why they're
doing it the more naturally the how
becomes easier and nothing has left the
conjecture if nothing is left
Superstition or Dogma or even in
spiritual
you know traditional words
you know science says the Contemporary
language would demystify that process
and you give new people numerous times
to overcome themselves and numerous
times to connect sooner or later you'll
start watching transformation right
before your eyes and so one of the cool
things that we've discovered is that we
have
so much compelling data to suggest that
you're greater than you think more
powerful than you no more unlimited than
you could ever dream we have compelling
data that suggests that your nervous
system is the greatest pharmacist in the
world that it makes drugs that work
better than any drug in a drugstore a
drug study is about 18 to 25 percent
cause and effect causality
our data is between 75 in 85 percent
cause and effect this is a person
creating their own Pharmacy of
anti-inflammatories their own Pharmacy
of anti-carcinogenic chemicals their own
Pharmacy of pain relievers who are
seeing this over and over again
so we have this incredible data that
says that this is no longer
pseudoscience is this the real this is
really science the side effect of a
person's transformation
is has changed my belief
in what's possible I have seen people
stand on the stage with stage four
cancers that were in every single organ
in their body and that metastasized and
and they have no sign of cancer in their
body and we have data that suggests that
you put the blood of an advanced
meditator and a uterine cancer cell a
pancreatic cancer cell
70 of the mitochondrial function in the
cancer cells diminish the mitochondria
is the energy packets of the cell it's
taking energy out of the cancer cell
works perfect with what we're seeing
with uh the testimonials uh that that
people are telling around the world
we've seen blind people see we've seen
deaf people here we've seen people with
spinal cord injuries walk again we've
seen
ALS change we've seen all kinds of
unbelievable health conditions Changed
by a person simply changing the way they
think the way they act and the way they
feel
if you're truly
in the business of change or creating
your life that's a big responsibility
yeah right I mean like we we ran our
event I said to the audience okay nobody
nobody forced you to come here right you
came here on your own you took the risk
in coming here
by coming here you also agree that
you create your reality that you're
responsible for yourself and your life
so if something happens to you you can't
blame anybody because of that it's your
responsibility to take care of you right
so then the fundamental question is and
I ask myself this all the time
at what point
do I stop believing
that I create my life at what point when
things go bad then all of a sudden I
didn't create that
that person is doing it to me right so
if we can if we can wire that in our
brains right that
our reaction in response to an
environmental condition
is causing us
to go back to the past that's what the
emotion is the familiar emotion is the
past
and I'm on the journey and I catch
myself doing that
if I'm truly in the practice every day
and I can cultivate a feeling not not
not on the spot then
that you you're not prepared
your meditation is the preparation of
mind and body for this
so I don't get up from my meditation
until I'm in love with life I don't I
don't create anything that's going to be
unlimited until I feel unlimited am I in
that space and if I'm practicing feeling
unlimited every day and practice
connecting to the emotions of my future
I'm I'm out of the bleachers and I'm on
the field if you're on the bleachers and
you're trying to not react to people in
in circumstances you don't have
the practice or the skill set
on how to create that emotion because
you haven't been practicing creating it
and why do we close our eyes and do it
because the environment is so seductive
why do we sit still and not move because
you're going to want to get up and pee
and eat and have a cup of coffee and
feel so so now you're telling your body
hey stay
I'm gonna feed you yeah you're gonna
take a shower you're gonna get coffee
you can play with your cell phone you
could text you can talk trash you can do
anything you want but right now you're
not the mind I'm the mind and you're
gonna sit and stay until I'm done and
when I condition you to the emotions of
the future and I get a very clear image
of who I'm going to be this day
and I'm not going to get up until I feel
that way
I guarantee you you're going to come up
against all those unconscious thoughts
they're going to come up right there I
want people that I want them to see it I
want them to become so familiar with it
so conscious if they wouldn't go
unconscious they wouldn't let that
thought I can't ever slip by their
awareness unchecked they've done the
work in the beginning of the day they
suppress those circuits in the brain and
nerve cells that no longer fire together
no longer wire together you're you're
breaking down the old personality and so
you say ah your body wants to get up I
gotta pee I want to have a couple I want
to check and you you watch your body
want to get up and you go hey hey hey
hey hey hey get over here you you get
back into this present moment and you
every time you do that it's a victory
you're executing a will that's greater
than an unconscious program and most
people lose their free will to a program
because they do the same thing today as
they did yesterday their bodies on
autopilot and it's dragging them into
the same future habitually based on what
they did in the past so now you're
sitting there and it's just a little
uncomfortable and you want to and you go
no
you get over here and you bring it back
now some people say I can't meditate but
really they're actually doing it right
that's a victory too yeah and then you
do that and you start watching how
you're training your body back into the
present moment then it's your body says
well
you know Lewis it's uh it's it's 8 8 30
in the morning this is usually when you
watch the news and throw a tirade and
get angry right and you're what's
sitting here with your eyes closed and
you're off schedule so why don't we just
get agitated about anything so the body
starts trying to create images in your
mind so you remember your ex you
remember your problems so you could feel
that agitation what if you watched your
body do that and you said
no no no no no I'm not going to give my
power away to the past or that person
that circumstance in my life you get
that body back in the present moment you
lower the volumes of that emotion
that's a victory you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind now that kind of work
is tedious in the beginning but I watch
people because when I have them do that
it starts stretching their boundaries
the known self that little box starts to
move into the unknown and they survive
and all of a sudden they're more relaxed
in the present moment the unknown and
they start feeling more satisfied so now
they're more ready to create so the
preparation for the day is to remind
yourself of who you no longer want to be
to know thyself to become so familiar
with the word meditation means to become
familiar with so conscious of your
unconscious programs you're not going to
go unconscious why because you did you
did battle today with that personality
that's creating the same personal
reality and if your personality is made
up of how you think how you act and how
you feel and you want to create new
personal reality then you got to change
your personality and that's gonna mean
then you're gonna become so conscious of
those unconscious programs that you're
no longer the program you're the
Consciousness observing the program
disentangling from that
is not easy that's why most people won't
do it that's why they get on their cell
phone and say let me just cradle
dopamine by just seeing if I got a text
from somebody I like you know your
phone's over there and you're no longer
regulating with something outside of you
this is this is game time so then if you
said
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain with my attention and my
intention when you're at a greater level
of awareness everything seems to be more
connected that's what the quantum is so
you're playing at that level the
synchronicities the serendipities the
coincidences are actually informing you
that you actually are creating your life
and that's the difference between being
the victim of your life and being the
creator of your life because when the
environment is controlling the way we
feel and the way we think some person
some circumstance some condition what
does that really mean that means that
person or circumstance is actually
causing me to think and feel a certain
way and and and I I don't think I have
any control of it then I must be victim
to that circumstance right and that's a
program right yeah so so I I realize in
my own Journey also that
if I don't change my response
to things in my life I'll never change
so so it's not even it's not that you
responded the question really is how
long right so when you become aware that
your environment is controlling how you
think and feel and your response changes
watch out because that now you no longer
belong to the Past
you actually belong to the Future so get
a coherent heart we know how to do that
really well get a go here and brain we
can do that really well have people take
all of their attention on off the
material world of everything known go
from a convergent Focus to a diversion
Focus we got the data to prove that if
you keep putting your attention on
nothing on Space somehow the brain gets
highly organized so now brain coherence
heart coherence you synchronize your
energy to whatever it is you want and
you got to sustain that state you can't
we've had people that have healed
themselves from Parkinson's disease from
cancers
from ALS literally remission of the
condition and then have bad news
and in one hour driving to the hospital
all of their symptoms came back after
being completely healed for two years
That's How Strong those emotions are
right so so so in your circumstance
right
I want people
I want people to have those moments
where they have to literally choose
because I think
when it's the hardest it matters the
most that's what I think so so all those
things where you're agitated with the
person having their moment you know that
could be you having your moment right
and you would want someone just like
that person doesn't want to do that
they're just having their thing if
people are really really believing that
their astrological sign determines their
Destiny then they will look for based on
their perception the correlations that
are equal to their belief system I don't
particularly believe that because I'm
born at a certain time under certain
house that has anything to do with me
creating the life that I want to have
right so
many people will though and because they
do they'll only they'll select like oh I
saw 11 11 on the clock well
you've seen three 236 on the clock and 4
18 on the clock but you're looking for
11 11. well then that's your reality
because that's where your attention is
right so I don't subscribe to that but I
respect that because that person is
going to keep that belief until it no
longer serves them and they're either
going to evolve their belief or they're
not and if they don't so be it but if
they do they're going to realize sooner
or later it's not working for them I
have certain beliefs right now
that I honestly am questioning that I
still think are limited beliefs but in
order for me to change those beliefs I'm
going to have to come out of my resting
state have to step out into the unknown
and really check to see and execute in a
very different way now
to build on that model
then it's going to require one foot
in the Practical world and one foot in
the Mysterious World because I can't
control all the events that happen in my
life but I can certainly make choices
that are going to bring me closer to
those experiences now I also know from
experience that when I'm living by the
hormones of stress and I'm living in
survival that you and I and everybody
else is always going to try to control
the outcome to try to force the outcome
to try to get in the way try to analyze
when it's going to happen and how it's
going to happen now when that occurs
we're really bad
we're competitive we're manipulative
we'll hold on to things we're deceitful
we're greedy but some of those chemicals
do so we're always trying to control and
force the outcome because in a sense we
feel separate from something greater we
feel like we're madder trying to change
matter we feel like we're we're
vibrating at the same speed as
everything else and so we have to get
what we want means you have to go and
get it in in and so then people start
mixing spiritual principles with that
phenomenon right so then
that's not what I'm talking about
because I'm talking about
if you're able
to understand that when you're living by
the hormones of stress that your senses
are heightened
and that you're materialist trying to
Define reality if you can't see it feel
a taste it smell it doesn't exist and
you're getting ready for something bad
to happen and be prepared and protect
yourself and that's how most people live
then everybody's doing that everybody's
mad at trying to change matter and the
soonerly we're going to bump into each
other and there's going to be Sparks
right so then is it possible then
that instead of being defined as a body
living in an environment in a particular
time
that if you were to close your eyes and
disconnect from the external environment
to sit your body down
into transcend time
and to become nobody
you have the biological Machinery to do
this to become no one you're not a face
you're not a man you're not a
documentary filmmaker
you're not your past you're not your
future you're not a husband
you're not your body you're not your
emotions you're not your habits you're
not the predictable future of the
familiar past
your pure consciousness
now if you are going to heal your body
by thought alone
if you are going to create some event in
your external environment by thought
alone and if you are going to transcend
Time by thought alone then you have to
become thought alone
and so when people start to really
realize that they can change the neural
circuitry in their brain by thought
alone send new emotional signals that
begin to select and up regulate new
genes and down regulate other genes and
it may take knocking on that door
for extended periods of time till
finally the gene is programmed because
it took them 10 years to program the
gene for the disease it may take them a
few years to reprogram the gene
now we're talking about pragmatist we're
talking about someone who's applying
some principles and so then when that
occurs
and the energy that was sitting in these
hormonal centers of survival of anger
and fear and guilt and shame the energy
kind of moves up a little bit we've
measured This Heart starts to open gets
more coherent the field around the body
begins to grow we've measured that the
person feels more like energy less like
matter they feel like more like wave
less like particle they're not afraid of
the unknown they let's go ahead and
answer that really quick he said like
the greatest part right now
you said knocking on the door I was like
Yeah ironic
[Music]
oh thank you
all right hopefully you didn't lose your
train of thought so
they're not afraid of the unknown
they're craving and they're trusting in
the unknown
and that that kind of expanded energy
is now their no longer
enslaved emotionally to the Past
they're no longer an identity that's
connected to a disease
they're no longer a body who's addicted
to an emotion they're no longer trying
to forecast the future based on the past
they're no longer a man they're no
longer a woman they're no longer a nurse
they're no longer black they're no
longer white they're no longer anything
they're they're a they are completely
poised in the present moment and that
that that present moment produces a
liberation of energy because the body is
no longer
held to the chains of the past and that
liberation of energy then begins to
produce a biological transformation in
the brain and the body we've seen it the
brain gets highly coherent gets super
organized the person feels whole
we've measured that their heart moves
into a state of joy and and love and
gratitude we measured that the field
around their bodies and hands we measure
that
and the person could no longer cares
about the future of the past they're
happy in the present moment they no
longer want anything because they're
whole
and if you're whole it's impossible to
want and that's the moment it happens
and so kind of this Paradox that begins
to occur so why am I explaining it like
this because I want to answer the
ultimate question of what you're asking
is that there's an intelligence that's
giving us life
it's keeping my heart beating and
digesting my food and food and
organizing trillions of functions per
second in every cell of my body I'm not
doing that I'm having a conversation
with you as a free-willed subject of
consciousness
but there's an intelligence within me
that's always endorsing who I'm being
and that intelligence is a Giver of Life
so to demystify it then and this is
where i s i part from the spiritual
community
because when your will
matches its will
when your mind matches its mind when
your love for Life matches its love for
life it begins to work in ways that are
mysterious now
why is that important because the
mysterious is the unknown and the
unknown is unexpected and the unexpected
should bring a surprise and that
surprise should be outside of my current
beliefs if it's happening how could I
expect the supernatural to happen if I'm
expecting it to happen
that it's impossible but if I'm in the
unknown and I'm open
to possibility then I should be able to
create an unknown experience that I
can't predict the emotion or the future
event of how it's going to occur when
it's going to occur it's not my job and
the side effect of that is this
mysterious surprise that changes my
biology from the new experience and then
causes me to change my beliefs and I've
I've had enough of my own mystical
moments in the midst of that mystical
experience I have said in the midst of
it I have this all wrong I have said it
right in the midst of the experience I
am doing this so wrong because I was so
programmed into this box of belief
but the only way the unexpected could
happen
is giving up expectation which means you
have to surrender that belief how it's
going to happen or when it's going to
happen I can't predict that so then that
same intelligence that's giving me life
according to the quantum model of
reality is the same intelligence that's
creating supernovas and causing flowers
to bloom it's it's within us and all
around us it's it's a very wave of
quantum physics I can't control that I
can't expect how the particle is going
to appear or when it's going to appear
but it's not my job
my job is to move into different states
of being and be open to the mystery of
how it's going to happen so
if I said to you today Ben that I had
all the answers
to everything I would I would certainly
be limiting this conversation but I am
open to the to the mystery of life and
the Mystery of Life then means that if
we're asking certain questions and we
believe we we even speculate that it's
possible and someone has to step out
into out of their present beliefs to see
if it is
and so I'm not interested in the natural
I'm not interested in the normal
I'm interested in the Supernatural the
super normal and I believe from my
present state of ignorance of course if
we're going to use the word belief
that you don't have to be a Buddhist
monk
you don't have to be a nun with 40 Years
of devotion you don't have to be a
religious scholar you don't have to be a
researcher you don't have to have a PhD
to do this
that common people around the world can
do the uncommon and if they're given the
right understanding
and the environment is set up where they
can begin the application of that
and I have looked at over a thousand
brain scans of people in meditation
and I can tell you that you and I are at
our absolute best when we get beyond our
analytical mind when we get Beyond
ourselves that's the moment that the
brain gets so organized and so coherent
the front of the brain is talking to the
back of the brain the right side of the
brain is talking on the left side of the
brain there's this synchronization this
psychic Union going on a flow and the
person has tears of joy rolling down
their face that Gestalt moment
that that
Transcendent event for the person is
completely subjective but my interest is
measuring that subjective experience and
we're capturing amplitudes of energy in
people's brains that are 26 000 to 40
000 times normal during that experience
now
they can't make their brain do that
it's happening to them and the inner
event that's happening to them is more
real than any past event and that's the
moment I know their belief is changing
be the example I mean show the world
what greatness looks like show the world
what love looks like show the world with
patience looks like show the world that
leadership looks like show the world so
that you can give people permission to
say wow
something's different about you like
what is it I want something what is that
what if don't go around telling people
you need the short you can forgive your
father you need to shorten your
emotional response don't do that show
the world what it looks like so they say
what is it what is it about you that's
different or the the you show up and
you're no longer matching the memory
they have of you like
who is this person yeah what happened to
you or what that's so important for
people because that means you're out of
face right so the world needs this is
not a time to to go to the Himalayas we
need you here we need you here yes we
need you to be the example you gotta
this is time to stand up for the truth
right and we gotta we gotta show the
world what it looks like and and every
single person creates that emerging
Consciousness every bird that's in that
pattern every fish that's in that school
that are moving is one mind and one
heart there is no leader everybody's
leading this is a time where everybody's
got to lead in this community absolutely
it's the Future No No health care plan
no religion excuse me
um
no government really is going to take
care of people the way they should be
taken care of right now and I don't mean
that in a in a secular way I'm sure
there's religions that really take care
of people but what I'm saying is we we
need to create a collective
Consciousness and Collective networks of
observers determine reality don't expect
anything in your life to change if your
environment
is controlling your feelings and
thoughts and if your environment is
controlling how you feel and think and I
say to you Bobby why are you so upset
today oh well this person is upsetting
me what you're really saying is that
person
is controlling your feelings and your
thoughts and that means you're a victim
to your environments well to turn that
around and you start realizing your
feelings and thoughts create your
environment
and you start seeing the effects of you
at cause
you're going to react less to the people
in your life because you're going to
understand that you'll be back to the
victim Consciousness and and when you
start seeing that you're creating
outcomes in your life you're going to
believe more that you're the creator of
your life unless the victim of your life
and I say the more you practice it
the better you get at it I think uh yeah
to heal by thought alone uh we have to
demystify the process so let's answer
the question on two levels okay
uh let's answer it in terms of the
placebo and then let's answer it in
terms of what we can teach people in
order to do that okay so if you think
about the placebo
how is it that you can give someone a
sugar pill
saline injection or perform some false
surgery or treatment
and a certain percentage of those people
will accept believe and surrender to the
thought that they're getting the real
substance or treatment without any
analysis they begin to program their
autonomic nervous system
to make their own Pharmacy of chemicals
that matches the exact chemical or
treatment they think they're getting now
was it the inert substance the placebo
that was doing the healing or was it the
thought that was doing the healing
so there are numerous cases in science
that show that between 10 percent and a
hundred percent of certain studies that
are placebo-based triple blind studies
people heal by thought alone all the
time so here's the question
do you need
the inner substance to do the healing or
if you understand the science and
mechanics of how the placebo Works can
you teach people instead of putting
their faith and belief in some exogenous
substance something outside of them like
a pill something certainly known can you
begin to put your faith and belief in
yourself
and begin to select an unknown in the
quantum field a new possibility that
already exists
and do the exact same thing you did with
the placebo but believe in a future
and allow your body to begin to respond
to a new mind and the answer to the
question is yes because we've measured
it enough times in our studies with the
brain so that's Point number one
the second point that is important to
understand is that people only accept
believe and surrender to the thoughts
that are equal to their emotional state
they'll never accept believe and
surrender to any other thoughts that are
not equal to their emotional state so if
you get a diagnosis and the first
emotion you feel after the diagnosis is
fear or sadness
you can think positively all you want
with five percent now this assigns five
percent of your conscious mind
but who you are by the time you're 35
years old is a subconscious program of
beliefs perceptions attitudes emotional
reactions unconscious habits and
behaviors
so then if the person gets the diagnosis
they're feeling fear thoughts are the
language of the brain feelings of the
language of the body
they're thinking positively with the
five percent of their conscious mind but
they're feeling fear
and they could do that all they want but
it's never going to get beyond their
analytical mind and begin to have an
effect on the body so mind and body are
working in opposition
that means also then that if you can
change a person's
emotional state
to gratitude
to inspiration
to Hope
uh to love
that means that they'll accept believe
and surrender to the thoughts equal to
that emotional state and they'll begin
to program their autonomic nervous
system into a different Pharmacy of
chemicals now let's just make this very
clear now in Placebo studies
81 of people who have
uh depression if they're in a placebo
study
and 81 of those people who are taking
the placebo actually respond as well to
the placebo as they would to an
antidepressant 81 percent that's a
pretty high study what that means is
they're making their own Pharmacy of
antidepressants right within the nervous
system is the greatest pharmacist in the
world
so what's the relevance uh the
significance of that significance is
really simple
and people begin to change their
emotional state they begin to alter who
they are
it may take more than one attempt at
this because in that Placebo study they
took the placebo for six to eight weeks
now the pill represented the possibility
of them getting well their thought
when they start looking forward to or
anticipating getting better and they
feel inspired when you combine a clear
intention with an elevated emotion
you're moving into a new state of being
now the brain and body are no longer
living in the past
the brain and body are living in the
future in the present moment and they're
beginning to produce substantial
neurological biological and genetic
changes in the body
but the placebo study for depression
that person took the pill for six to
eight weeks which means you may actually
have to change your state of being for
six to eight weeks before you begin to
see the change so I don't want this to
be a Panacea where you do it once and
you're better our students have healed
themselves a very significant
very very uh
most almost predestined genetic
conditions that medical science had no
solution for not just one student with
one condition but other students with
the same condition now we're seeing a
trend but it took them some of those
people
two years to do it by thought alone
so they wanted it more than their sleep
they wanted it more than their pain they
wanted it more than their social
interactions or social engagements they
wanted more than breakfast to them it
was the most important thing so every
single day
they took the placebo by thought alone
and by doing that over time they were
able to turn the battleship around
so it takes
developing the skill it takes the
science of understanding how it works it
takes changing the belief or perception
that you have about yourself and your
life and it's going to take you feeling
a little bit uncomfortable in the
process of doing it but to heal by
thought alone means that you have to get
to the point where you literally are
thought alone that's when you begin to
see the significant changes how you
think and how you feel creates your
state of being if you take a thought and
a feeling a thought and a feeling of
thought and a feeling of thought and a
feeling it's called an attitude yes
there's a good thoughts with a series of
Good Feelings you say I have a good
attitude today in a series of negative
thoughts that are connected to a series
of negative feelings you have a bad
attitude today so attitudes are just
shortened states of being good attitude
in the morning bad attitude in the
afternoon if you take an attitude and
attitude imagine you keep those up any
string attitudes together you create
what's called a belief and a belief is
just an extended state of being so if
you keep thinking the same thought you
keep hardwiring in the brain you keep
feeling the same feeling you keep
conditioning in your body the redundancy
of that cycle over and over again
conditions the body to subconsciously
become the mind of that belief and all
beliefs
our subconscious states of being okay
take a belief a belief a belief in your
string them together you form what's
called a perception and perceptions are
just such extended states of being
that we're unconscious and so then we we
edit out reality in fact most people
don't see things the way they are they
see things the way they are right and
people are always feeling in reality
unconsciously based on their memory they
could be married to a person for 40
years and they don't see the person they
see the memory of the person right and
there's research to prove this okay so
how do we change the belief or
perception about ourself for our lives
okay we've studied this
okay let's just say that lack is
ingrained in there you got the story you
lived on the streets you lost everything
you got betrayed your business partner
took everything took your wife took you
got the story in the half okay okay you
guys start telling the new story of the
future right you got to believe in that
future more than you have to believe in
the past so how do you do that you only
believe in the past when you feel the
emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
of the future right okay so in order for
us to change a belief or perception
about ourself and our lives
we have to make a decision
with such firm intention
the amplitude of that decision carries a
level of energy
that's greater than the hardware
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we down
regulate that old belief if the trauma
created an emotional quotient of sex
or seven then your decision to change
your beliefs got to be a nine right and
you got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
because you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created with some
strong emotion right but at the
amplitude of that emotion is greater
than the Betrayal Boom the body starts
responding to mind and
they're actually giving your body a
taste of the future emotionally so you
brand your voice impossible no your
body's actually getting the taste of
that future event experiencing the
future now exactly big explosion on the
quantum field big explosion so the side
effect of that
is if you combine that clear intention
with that elevated emotion you're
basically remembering your future and it
looks no different than remembering your
past think neurologically within the
circuits of that memory and feel within
the emotions of that new belief and
watch your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lacking or lack or separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for us
to become abundant
we have to overcome the old personality
meditation the actual translation of the
word meditation means to become familiar
with so the first thing you have to do
is you have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation meditation
the actual translation of the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
Network in your brain every experience
that you have with every person produces
an emotion so some people will use their
boss to reaffirm their addiction to
judgment they'll use their enemy to
reaffirm their addiction to hatred
they'll use their friends to reaffirm
their addiction to suffering so now they
need the outer world to feel something
so
to change then is to be greater than
your environment to be greater than the
conditions in your world and the
environment is that seductive so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's Close Our Eyes
let's disconnect from your outer
environment so if you're seeing less
things there's less stimulation going to
your brain if you're playing soft music
or you have earplugs in less sensory
information coming to your brain so
you're disconnecting from your
environment if you can sit your body
down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here I'm gonna feed you when we're
done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then when you do that properly and
you're not eating anything or smelling
anything or tasting anything you're not
up experiencing and feeling anything you
would have to agree with me that you're
being defined by a thought right so when
the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy you're siphoning your energy out
of the present moment into the past and
you become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's eight o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling anger and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions and you settle it back
down into the present moment you're
telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will is getting
greater than the program and if you keep
doing this over and over again over and
over again over and over again just like
training a stallion or dog it's just
gonna say I'm gonna sit and the moment
that happens when the body's no longer
the mind when it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
it's so important for people
to remember that they're the creators of
their lives instead of the victim of
their lives right so the victim is
saying I'm feeling this way because that
person or that circumstance or I don't
have any money is causing me to feel
this way that's my relationship with
money what that really means is I'm
using my lack to reaffirm my dependency
my addiction my conditioning that's my
relationship with money is that I put my
attention on money because I don't have
it so the relationship with money is of
course built on lack and so when they
don't have it they feel bad and what
they're really saying is my outer
environment my reality is actually
controlling the way I feel the way I
think so Louis why are you in a good
mood today things are going good why in
a bad mood things are going bad today so
this unconscious program victimization
is saying that that that we're we're
allowing our environment to influence
the way we feel and the way we think
isn't that isn't that what victimization
is and and the stronger the emotion we
have to our lack the more we put our
attention on the fact that we don't have
it right so then the person has
forgotten that they're creating reality
because what they're creating is lack
and they're creating more of it and then
they try harder and they force harder
and they can they're so exhausted and
their body's tired and they're breaking
down right so so the experiment then is
let's try it another way let's create
from the field instead of from matter
can a coherent heart get a coherent
brain relax in the heart and energy
moves right in the brain we've measure
this thousand times and all of a sudden
the person moves into these beautiful
elegant brainwave states where they're
super creative right so the the longer
you're conscious of that energy the more
you draw that future to you so then what
is the synchronicity mean it means
whatever you're doing inside of you is
producing that effect outside of you pay
attention to what you did do it again so
generate a little bit more abundance
just do it for an experiment now when
the synchronicity happens do you think
you feel suffering or do you think you
feel a little excitement you feel
inspired right so then that
synchronicity is saying use this energy
and use this feeling it should be easier
for you to feel this now and go back and
do it again keep the experiment going
and here comes the promotion here comes
the here comes the email here comes the
person you meet at the right time right
well we have something happening here
and then that that becomes the momentum
right
so then we generate abundance that's
that's how we do it and the relationship
just happen by accident we generate we
generate abundance right so then if you
have an hour meditation where you're
tuning into your abundant future
but then you're spending the other 15
hours a day in lack don't expect
anything to change you defaulted and
you're back to the old energy and if you
say it's that person or that
circumstance or that bank account I'm
going to say you're back to the
unconscious program being a victim right
and so then so then
so then let's go a step further
if your personality creates your
personal reality and it does and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel then the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called their life
nothing big there which means if you
want to change your personal reality
you're going to have to change your
personality right nothing changes in
your life until you change the moment
you lose the feeling of your future you
start looking for it
because you feel separate from it but if
you feel it why would you look for it
because you feel like it already
happened that's when the magic happens
boom that's an epiphany that's like whoa
yeah when you look for it you feeling it
you're separate from it yeah so when
people start learning how to we have we
have documentation yeah people in this
work can sustain hard coherence for 45
minutes to an hour they know that they
know how to do it can you teach your
body emotionally
what the future reality that you want to
live in feels like before it happens now
this is very difficult if you've been
conditioned into believing something
your outer world has to change to make a
way take away the emptiness or the lack
to make you feel differently this is
saying actually feel the emotion before
it happens and don't wait for the
experience to occur teach your body what
the feeling will be before it occurs if
the environment signals the Gene and the
end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion you're
signaling the gene ahead of the
environment and genes make proteins and
proteins are responsible for the
structure and function of your body and
the expression of proteins is the
expression of life so teach the body
emotionally to self-regulate to believe
it's living in an environment that's
flourishing that's wonderful keep
practicing it and it'll become familiar
to you and the process then
creates a new identity and it's not
difficult once you understand what
you're doing and why you're doing it and
the more you combine all those different
branches of science and make it in a
simple way to understand if people
understand the what and the why the how
gets easier because you can assign
meaning to what you're doing and it
becomes instrumental so get a group of
people a thousand people 1500 people 2
000 people into a room
teach them that information whether
they're coming for wealth or health a
relationship a new career a mystical
experience get them all together
and teach them and measure what can take
place in one week period of time and I
assure you that's more than 75 percent
of the people that go through and go all
in and Retreat from their lives and
remove the same stimulation from their
environment and not be in the same
conditions and teach them that
information and give them numerous
opportunities to apply it and numerous
opportunities to get Beyond themselves
all you need is that first person that
stands on the stage and says hey I
walked in here with Parkinson's disease
I have no idea what happened but I'm not
trembling anymore and boy that last
thing just something clicked for me and
the person in the audience is watching
the four minute mile right in front of
them and going wow that guy looks like
he's not a vegan he doesn't look like
he's particularly in shape but his
Parkinson's went away and wow I mean if
he could do it I could do it and
somebody else changes their belief and
now that's a footprint and Consciousness
get enough people doing that
by the end of the week you're going to
see things we've seen blind people
seeing deaf people hearing that once not
twice people with Strokes for 10 years
lift their arms up again we've seen
people step out of wheelchairs people on
crutches drop their cracks I mean you
see
the body literally recalibrates to a new
mind and and they're not intentionally
trying to do anything they're just
becoming somebody else but the process
of overcoming
is the process of becoming and if you
teach people that formula and you get
just one or two people doing it it's
just going to become an infection and
it's gonna Wellness is gonna spread just
like disease if you don't know
that that's possible right then it
doesn't exist for you right like if
you're if you're unconscious to the fact
that you could heal yourself you'll make
the same choices you always do
so so I'm challenged in my own way at a
different level to to do my best to do
the right make the right choices all the
time and sometimes those choices
um I can't I can't rely on anybody else
but me to make those choices because
nobody else knows what it's like to be
me than me even my closest friends think
they know me but they but when it comes
down to making the choice it's a lonely
moment right because I'm doing my best
to try to preserve this work and to
inspire people to apply it in their
lives as many ways as I can so so a lot
of times I get discouraged like oh my
God like another challenge another
challenge but you know I think you know
when I'm truly
in the right Zone I I think the only way
that we actually can grow in our lives
is to be challenged right so and I think
that I think greater the greater we
evolve or the greater we become I think
the greater the challenge is you know
and so so I'm I have my own set of
challenges that I have to really Retreat
from my life
I've spent a lot of time alone enough to
remember that vision and I have to and I
have this I have to get beyond all those
other things that say oh my God this is
this might be a good time for you to
quit this is a good time for you as well
this is getting pretty intense I think
it's a time in history where it's not
enough to know it's a time in history to
know how
and if you think about it um
most people live their life in a habit
they think the same thoughts they
perform the same actions they live by
the same emotions but they secretly
expect their life to change
but how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality and
your personality creates your personal
reality that's it so if you think 60 to
70 000 thoughts in one day and ninety
percent of those thoughts are the same
thoughts as the day before the same
thoughts always lead to the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same emotions
and those same emotions then drive your
very same thoughts and so you get caught
in this kind of biological neurological
and Quantum fixated pattern so then the
hardest part about change really in
creating the life that you want being
defined by a vision of the future
instead of a memory of the past is not
making the same choices you did the day
before and the moment you do that you
step into the unknown now you and I have
been conditioned and hypnotized into
believing that the unknown is some scary
place but when you begin to realize the
unknown is the perfect place to create
from that void of unpredictability and
uncertainty that unfamiliarity is really
the quantum place of uncertainty where
all manifestations come from so when you
and I become comfortable living in that
unknown place I think then that we begin
to manifest the things we want in our
lives so for me personally
I want to execute and be defined by a
vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past so most people's
brains are organized to reflect
everything they know in their life their
brain is a record of the past
and if you feel the same way every
single day and feelings and emotions are
the end product of past experiences it
means number one nothing new is
happening in your life and number two
those emotions are keeping you anchored
to the past if thoughts are the language
of the brain and feelings are the
language of the body and how you think
and how you feel creates a state of
being most people are literally
biologically neurologically chemically
genetically and even Quantum wise
connected to a past
so then the question is the fundamental
question is
can you believe in a future that you
can't see or experience with your senses
yet but you've thought about enough
times in your mind that your brain has
literally changed to look like the
experience has already occurred now the
latest research in neuroscience and
neuroplasticity tells us we can change
our brain to look like the event has
already occurred and can we begin to
emotionally Embrace a future reality
that's a potential in the quantum field
and begin to emotionally embrace it to
such agree that we fall in love with
that future reality that our body is our
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and we're signaling new
genes in new ways to change our body to
look like the experience has already
occurred in preparation for the event
now think about this so making our inner
World more real than the outer world
right but not only that
you have to then understand that when
you truly do this properly you're not
waiting for your healing to feel whole
you're not waiting for your success to
feel empowered you're not waiting for
your wealth to feel abundant you're not
waiting for your new relationship to
feel love you're not waiting for the
mystical moment to feel awe that's the
old model of reality of cause and effect
waiting for something outside of you to
change how you feel inside of you and
when you feel better inside and you pay
attention to whoever whatever caused
that that's that's cause and effect and
when you begin to make the correlation
between what changed you from outside
and inside you create an associate of
memory
want the model of reality it begins to
say then you have to teach your body
emotionally how that future is going to
feel like before it's made manifest in
other words you have to feel awe an
order for the mystical moment to happen
you have to feel abundance before your
wealth can occur you have to feel in
love with life before your new
relationship happens and so we're not
defining Reality by our senses because
we're not waiting then for anything
outside of us to change how we feel
inside of us so if there's physical
evidence in your brain and body to look
like the experience has already occurred
physical evidence
because the epigenetic model of reality
says you can change your body by thought
alone you and neuroplasticity says you
can change your brain by thought alone
so if there's physical evidence to look
like the experience has already occurred
well relax because the experience is
going to find you and it's going to come
in a way that you least expect believe
in the thought I can't meditate or I
don't have enough time or I'm a really
important person or I got too many too
many emails to answer it's garbage day
or it's my mother's fault it's my ex's
fault I want to complain I want to blame
them to make excuses I want to lay down
my bladder is full I like this what am I
doing wrong and they're agitated and
patient that's
that's the personality that has been
hardwired
and conditioned emotionally into the
past that's resisting the unknown it
would rather cling to suffering than
take a chance and possibilities so our
events we say okay here's the knowledge
and I can say now with
a great degree of certainty more than
ever that if you actually do this and
you stretch yourself a little bit
further
than where you would normally go at home
your brain will change and if you teach
people how to do this
over and over again and no different
than training an animal the body is the
animal are you training the body that
you're in charge is that what you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind yes and when you do
that those victories add up and all of a
sudden there's a liberation of energy
there goes the guilt there goes the pain
there goes the whatever it doesn't
matter if it's Health it doesn't matter
if it's wealth or success it doesn't
matter if it's a loving relationship a
change in a career or mystical
experience whatever it is the person all
of a sudden starts to relax into the
present moment I think we're a reality
producing machines I mean there's no
there's no single individual on this
planet
who doesn't create reality unless they
have a brain injury or something but for
the most part most of us are engaged in
reality you know and we do cause effects
I think we reach a certain point in our
life where we stop learning and we start
feeling and when we use feelings as a
barometer for the unknown
it's a it's it's contraindicated because
feelings are usually a record of a past
experience so we try to predict how that
future event is going to be based on a
Feeling and we always return back to the
old self again so
I love the idea of how we can actually
produce effects I love the idea that
every human being is either lives in one
of two states of mind we either live in
creation which is growth and expansion
and and it's um health and homeostasis
the emotions of love and joy and Trust
make us feel connected to something
bigger than us or we live in a state of
survival in a state of survivals living
in stress and living in stress is when
your body is knocked out of balance and
the redundancy of that cycle over time
that imbalance that keeps happening
begins to break the body down and I
think the biggest problem for us because
of the size of our brains is we can turn
on the stress response just by thought
alone and we do it all day long
in that continuous redundant
being out of balance over time that
imbalance becomes the new balance and
now we're headed for contraction and
disease and feeling separate from the
field and being selfish instead of
selfless we begin to
live in a state of breakdown in a state
of um
uh disease and a lack of health and and
so then those emotions then of those
survival chemicals endorses the ego and
then we become more self-indulgent and
more self-important and more
self-serving
because that's what those chemicals do
so
we live in one of those two states of
mind now those chemicals tend to be
highly addictive so this is really good
dinner conversation we can talk about it
right
but actually breaking through that's I
think when you free yourself from the
chains of those emotions that that we
memorize when we actually break through
and our when we remove
that mind out of the body when we break
the emotion that's trapped in physical
flesh and the body's liberated that's
true self-love that's true Joy it's the
liberation of energy so the anger that
once was in there the hatred that was
once into the Prejudice that was once in
there is transformed it's transmuted
into joy and it's the same energy but it
just has a different spin
and so no one can do that for you
you know that that isn't something where
someone you know waves a wand and then
it happens you have to actually be
willing to be uncomfortable
as you break that addiction and be okay
with it and then the moment the body's
liberated
and you feel that expansion that's the
natural state of being now you say I
love myself so much because I went
further than I thought I could go
I transcended some limitation about
myself in the way I think in the way I
act in the way I feel that's the
personality that's the identity
changing one of those things
really changing and not just like
changing your mind like I want vanilla
ice cream instead of chocolate ice cream
but truly changing something that
changes your neurology or neural
circuitry changes the chemistry which is
your emotions that signal the gene that
begins to change your very expression of
Health in a very expression of life
talking about when you make that
emphatic you know declaration work you
make that change
and it's undeniable
there's a biological neurological and
Quantum effect as a result of it well I
think I flirt primarily with the idea of
how subjective mind has an effect on the
objective world
you know Newtonian physics is about
cause and effect it's about something
outside of you fundamentally changing
something inside of you you know we are
an expression or a reflection of the
environment
so
as long as the environment is
influencing how we're thinking and
feeling we can only be as great as the
environment so and if we're thinking and
feeling equal to the environment we
could only create more of the same
environment you know the idea that we
can change something inside of us in our
in our Consciousness and our thoughts
and in our feelings
and be able to memorize both
neurologically in our brain and hardwire
that information install Hardware
and condition the body emotionally to be
a mind so mind and body are working
together
if we're able to maintain that modified
state of being then
there should be some evidence outside of
us so instead of cause and effect
I always love the idea of causing
effects and it's a cause and effect so
the quantum model says you can cause an
effect and so I think where we get stuck
with that is the idea that you know that
it has to be predictable that we should
be able to know how it's going to happen
and that is that is I think our biggest
error because we can never control the
outcome of the unpredictable that's the
quantum model it has to be uncertain it
has to come in a way that we least
expect that surprises us that that
leaves no doubt that what we did inside
of us produced some effect outside of us
and and when you begin to have those
small synchronicities at first and then
they turn into larger and larger events
and you experience that
that awe and that Wonder or that joy and
appreciation for being alive I think
that's the natural state of being I
think that's
having that kind of sensibility coming
from within us instead of needing
something outside of us to change our
state I want to sense then it's not the
personality that chooses the body or the
parents or it's the soul that chooses it
does that make sense but if a person
gets caught in routine and gets lost in
the Quagmire of life
then the ego takes over and the soul is
diminished
and now the person is doing their best
to become a somebody a someone on
something be somewhere in some time and
of course if that's the journey
the person's not willing to find wisdom
or look for truth then they can play on
that level for as long as they want
until they're tired of it and when they
finally get bored with it and they'll
they'll want to choose something else
and Eternity is a long time wouldn't you
agree
so then the Soul then says okay here's
the options probable lines of time there
are probable lines of time that are the
more probable than others
and
there is a probable line of time for
living in the same body and raising your
frequency to the point where you can go
wherever you want with your body that's
the ultimate yes or no and you can whip
red out of nothing and you can be in two
places at once and you can be on the the
uh an alternate universe and have a
whole life there and you can be
dimensional that's that's the freedom of
when you've mastered yourself and you've
mastered the conditions
but most of us
are headed in a certain timeline based
on our genes and based on our own
personal Evolution and that's what makes
this time right now
so powerful
this time right now is the age of
information
and an age of information ignorance is
actually a choice
and people are beginning to realize that
I'm going to need a doctor to find out
what my disease is I don't need to go to
the library or talk to my teacher I can
just I can just find the information and
people are starting to wake up to
Greater understandings and that is
starting to become the collective and
that Collective energy in the field the
collective Consciousness the collective
awareness is changing the future of
humanity yes or no and at the same time
past is crumbling
there is economic collapse there's
political collapse there's religious
collapse there's environmental collapse
there's there's all of that is breaking
down journalistic collapse and well who
watches the news and expects to hear the
truth I mean it's just all falling apart
and it's becoming so obvious
to people that all of a sudden they're
realizing that the people that run the
world or people that are in places of
Power are actually really really worse
off than you and I
and the only thing that has to happen is
that we have to collectively become one
mind
and when we collectively become one mind
we no longer are seduced by those things
and we are now like a flock of birds all
moving in the same direction of those
fish all of a sudden moving as a school
nobody's leading everybody's leading
we're just connected and what do you
think we're doing when you tune in to
the power of love in this room don't you
know everybody dialing into that same
frequency is causing that frequency to
be in this room and if everybody's doing
it it's getting more collimated more
coherent more organized and if you put
your attention on it there's more of it
so then when you're leading with your
heart that's enough
that's enough
so then when you have a collective mind
and people are moving in that way and
they're no longer reacting to politics
or whatever and they no longer need
those things you're catching somebody
who's starting to awaken
yes or no and if you're focusing on the
Divine and that's where all of your
attention is you won't see ethnicity you
won't see skin color you won't see
anything of Separation you'll just be
like wow
nice costume to the masquerade I should
have wore that
it's crazy because then people go get
their genetics found out and you know
some of them you know just really have
an intolerance to some culture and
they're 40 percent of that culture
so
what makes this time for me so unique
and I'm speaking
personally
is that there's such a quickening going
on more things are happening in a
shorter amount of time would you agree
and if more things are happening in a
shorter amount of time it becomes more
difficult to predict the next moment
this point where reaching this nodal
point is the point of in
unpredictability and the old is
collapsing and the collapsing of the old
should never be faced with fear was
bigotry with with with anger with
hostility with guilt sadness and shame
because that's how we've been controlled
all along
and by the way
I mean I'm not a conspiracy theorist but
if you want to control people manipulate
their emotions so as we move closer and
closer to that point the probability of
US changing our life the length of our
life not from low stress foods and not
from vitamins all those things are good
matter to matter
but stress is going to down regulate the
gene consume the body's energy and now
that's going to begin to Signal the gene
to produce the disease that the person
has inherited in the first place
are you with me still so when you react
to someone or something and you're
living by the same emotional state you
keep the same genes on the same genes
off and that's your genetic Destiny and
now the Awakening of this even if I
even if we change little timelines just
this week we changed lines of time
you've changed something about yourself
you are going to walk into a different
future that is your genetic timeline and
now you're bumped off course you just
got to be willing to stay in the unknown
and be comfortable with it and that's
when you're at your greatest
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to master
the art of manifesting check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there true spirituality is about not
wanting is about being filled with joy
from inside and then sharing that
outside it's not about attracting to
yourself what you want people ask me is
there a law of attraction yes and you
better be scared of it because if it's
true that you attract